en el último vídeo estuvimos platicando
acerca de los vectores sin embargo lo
vimos una forma un poco abstracta y
formal matemática en la cual no vimos
muchos ejemplos en esta ocasión quiero
ver bastantes ejemplos de vectores y sin
embargo todos estos vectores van a estar
en r2 también trabajamos lo que era las
sumas la multiplicación por escalar y
además definimos quién era el vector sep
y bueno la razón de por qué voy a
trabajar en esta ocasión en r2 es porque
r2 se puede representar con un plano y
un plano es bastante visible y podemos
trabajar bastante bien con él pero bueno
la vez pasada vimos una definición de r2
recuerdan r2 era el conjunto de duplas
que además cumplían que era un conjunto
ordenado de duplas x 1 x 2 m poniendo
aquí y ponerlo bien porque está con más
se parecía el 1 y entonces eran parejas
de números tales que cada uno de estos
números existía en los números reales
tanto x1 es un número real como x2 es un
número real y bueno es por eso que
entonces podemos ver que r2 es decir
éste
lo podemos visualizar como el plano
cartesiano en el cual tenemos un eje de
las abscisas y una eje de las ordenadas
entonces ya está tenemos aquí el plano
cartesiano y si te das cuenta cualquier
punto de este plano cartesiano si
hacemos este plano cartesiano infinito y
lo hacemos muy pero muy grande este
plano cartesiano va a representar a
todos los puntos de r2 oa todos los
posibles valores que puede tomar
cualquier pareja de números en r2 es por
eso que erre 2 lo podemos representar
con el plano cartesiano pero bueno la
idea de este vídeo no es hablar de r2
realmente yo lo que quiero hablar es de
los vectores y visualizados en r2 sin
embargo esta es la razón por la cual voy
a utilizar a r2 como base para ello
poder hablarles de vectores y bueno mis
vectores van a ser vectores de dos
componentes para que los podamos
visualizar en r2 así que vamos a tomar
los dos vectores me voy a tomar el
vector menos 12 este vector va a ser mi
vector am recuerden que es una gruesa
para que no se confunda con una escalar
y p gruesa va a ser mi segundo vector el
cual va a ser
es el 31 este va a ser mi segundo vector
bueno ya que tengo mis dos vectores
recuerden cómo definimos la suma de dos
vectores la suma de dos vectores le
habíamos definido la vez pasada como la
suma componente a componente es decir
tomábamos la primer componente del
primer vector y la suma vamos con la
primer componente del segundo vector la
segunda componente del primer vector la
vamos a sumar con la segunda componente
del segundo vector así me queda entonces
que a más bebek tores me van a quedar
menos 13 es decir la primer componente
de ambas la primera componente deben y
después dos más uno es decir la segunda
componente de a más la segunda
componente debe y menos 132 y dos más
uno es tres y ya acabamos la suma de
ambas bien la suma de vectores y bueno
ahora ya que tenemos a estos dos
vectores y los dos vectores tienen dos
componentes sería muy lógico pensar que
entonces a estos vectores los podemos
representar como puntos en este plano
cartesiano por ejemplo recordemos aquí
tenemos el punto 1.1 y esto qué quiere
decir quiere decir que tenemos uno en el
eje de las abscisas y uno
en el eje de las ordenadas caminamos uno
en el eje de las abscisas después
caminamos uno en el eje de las ordenadas
y me quedaría aquí mi punto no no no de
hecho esperen ese sería el 22 aquí está
el 1 aquí está el 1 y entonces caminamos
1 en el eje de las abscisas 1 en el eje
de las ordenadas y este sería mi punto
11 sin embargo en vectores no es lo
mismo ten cuidado un vector además de
tener dos componentes también necesita
tener un origen qué quiere decir esto
bueno primero lo que tenemos que hacer
es de todos los puntos de este plano
cartesiano de todos hay que elegir un
origen puede ser el punto que tú quieras
pero sí es muy importante tomar un
origen así que voy a suponer que el
origen es x1 x2 éste puede ser cualquier
punto en el plano por lo tanto vamos a
escribirlo cualquier punto en todo r2
cualquier punto en el plano puede ser
nuestro origen o nuestro punto inicial
por lo tanto ya que tenemos definido x1
y x2 como se podría ver el vector a en
los ojos de este punto inicial bueno
pues entonces
va a ser igual a x1 menos uno es decir
la primera coordenada del punto inicial
le vamos a sumar la primera coordenada
de el vector a y después x dos más dos
porque lo que estamos haciendo es tomar
la segunda coordenada de este punto
inicial y sumándole la segunda
coordenada de nuestro vector así que por
ejemplo si nosotros tomamos cualquier
punto de este plano supongamos este de
aquí vamos a tomar cualquier punto de
este plano en este caso es el 4 el menos
44 entonces cómo se va a ver
representado a bueno para esto lo que
tenemos que hacer es primero a este
punto menos 4 4 es decir nuestro origen
o nuestro punto inicial sumarle a la
primera coordenada menos 1 y a la
segunda coordenada 2 así que vamos a
escribirlo lo que voy a hacer es a este
punto
al menos 44 le voy a sumar a la primera
coordenada la primera componente del
vector a y me va a quedar menos cuatro
menos uno de la segunda coordenada le
voy a sumar la segunda componente del
vector y me va a quedar cuatro más dos
es decir nosotros nos tenemos que fijar
en el punto menos 56 y
lo que voy a hacer aquí 4 - 1 me va a
dar menos 5 y 429 va a dar 6 voy a
caminar unos y la izquierda y después
subir 2 unidades y entonces mi vector va
a ser justo este que estoy dibujando
aquí es más déjenme ponerlo mucho más
claro y entonces deje el nuevo resto que
tengo aquí y voy a poner aquí a mi punto
final en el punto en el que llego y
entonces mi vector va a ser la flecha
que va del punto inicial al punto final
y esta es mi representación del vector y
bueno como ven puedo tomar cualquier
punto inicial que yo desee supongamos
este de aquí este punto va a ser el 46 y
entonces yo me tengo que mover uno hacia
la izquierda me va a quedar cuatro menos
uno lo cual me va a dar tres y después
seis más dos lo cual me va a dar 83 y
aquí 8 y entonces el vector va a ser la
flecha del punto inicial al punto final
va a ser este de aquí unimos los dos
puntos con una línea y la flecha va a
indicar de qué punto a qué punto vamos
es decir quién es mi punto de inicio y
que es mi punto final
y es más a es de color azul entonces
déjenme ponerlos naves de color azul
porque voy a utilizar el color verde
para ver entonces estas dos flechas
representan al vector am tanto ésta como
esta y para no poner a guardar recuerdan
que también les había comentado que se
denota con una a con una flecha encima
entonces tomamos un punto inicial
caminamos uno a la izquierda después dos
para arriba y ese va a ser mi vector
si nosotros definimos nuestro punto
inicial y bueno lo mismo para ver yo
agarro un punto inicial para ver
supongamos este el menos ocho como al
menos cuatro y después nos fijamos en
los componentes hay que caminar 13 la
derecha 123 porque es nuestra primera
componente y 1 hacia arriba porque es la
segunda componente y entonces la flecha
que va del punto inicial al punto final
va a ser nuestro vector b por ejemplo
aquí puedo tomar el mismo punto inicial
y caminar 13 la derecha y 1 hacia arriba
y entonces esta flecha que va a estar
desde el inicio hasta el final va a ser
mi vector b y recuerden que escribo ve
con una flecha arriba para representar
que es un vector y si se dan cuenta
tanto a como
llenan todo el plano cartesiano hay un
buen de vectores en este plano
cartesiano y un buen de vectores ve en
el plano cartesiano sin embargo casi
siempre cuando nos referimos a un vector
estamos hablando de su posición estándar
y su posición estándar no es ni más ni
menos que centrar este vector en donde
creen en el origen es decir en el 0 0
así es la convención y es que si es
mucho más fácil trabajarlos por lo tanto
si nos centramos como punto inicial en
el 0,0 este de aquí va a ser nuestro
vector am y vez se va a ver de la
siguiente manera hay que caminar 3 a la
derecha 1 2 3 y 1 hacia arriba y
entonces tendríamos al vector b que al
final representan puntos en el plano o
más bien representar a la flecha que se
forma desde el origen desde el punto 0 0
hasta el punto en el plano que
representa las dos componentes de este
vector y bueno ahora la pregunta va a
ser cómo represento la suma de estos dos
vectores y si te das cuenta me suma es
el 23 donde estaría 23 este de aquí es
la suma de ambas ven cómo llego de estos
dos vectores a la suma
estos dos vectores y si te das cuenta la
suma de dos vectores también es un
vector porque también me da dos
coordenadas y un punto de origen
esta es la suma del vector a más el
vector b entonces este de rojo es el
vector am más el vector b y bueno ahora
la pregunta es nosotros tenemos aquí un
vector a y aquí tenemos un vector ver
representados gráficamente en este plano
cartesiano cómo podemos llegar
gráficamente a la suma de estos dos
vectores es decir de dónde sale este
vector de rojo de a más ven y bueno lo
único que hay que hacer es fijarnos un
poquito en lo que es la cola del vector
de la punta del vector es decir vamos a
fijarnos en el final del vector a en el
final del vector am es decir la cabeza
de a vamos a unirlo con la cola del
vector de en el vector b es el 31 por lo
tanto hay que caminar 3 a la derecha 123
y 1 hacia arriba y 1 hacia arriba que
creen ya encontré aquí el vector
resultante de la suma de a con b se dan
cuenta llegué al mismo punto y lo único
que hice fue poner
después de otro así que la suma
representada de una manera geométrica
también ya la tenemos lo único que hay
que hacer es unir el final de un vector
con el inicio del otro el final del
vector a con el inicio del vector b y
por lo tanto la resultante o el vector
que me queda de la suma de cumbe va a
ser este de rojo que tengo aquí es decir
a que es el vector 12 con b que es el
vector 3-1 al sumarlos me queda el
vector 23 y vamos a ver otro ejemplo
aquí abajo si agarramos otro punto
inicial otro origen me va a salir lo
mismo camino 3 a la derecha 1 se arriba
1 el principio con el final y ya con
esto obtengo la suma de más b es decir
el vector resultante va a ser aquel
vector que va a iniciar en el punto de
origen en el punto de origen de estos
dos vectores y va a terminar en el punto
final a donde llega la flecha del vector
b por lo tanto aquí tengo a más fe y ya
tengo una representación gráfica dado
cualquier punto de origen dado cualquier
punto en el cual empecemos
ya sé qué onda con la suma ahora vamos a
pensar qué onda con la siguiente
operación que definir la vez pasada con
la multiplicación por un escalar así que
tomemos un vector vamos a llamarlo b
este vector de va a ser el siguiente
vector fíjense que yo estoy poniendo con
un ave un poco más gruesa para
representar que es un vector y vamos a
decir que este vector b es el 12 bueno
ya que tengo este vector ven ahora como
lo pongo en posición estándar bueno en
posición estándar
recuerden que empezamos en el origen por
lo tanto caminamos 1 a la derecha
2 hacia arriba y me quedaría este vector
de aquí ahora bien si no estuviera en
posición estándar podemos agarrar
cualquier punto de origen caminar uno a
la derecha y uno hacia arriba y
tendremos este vector que está aquí este
es el vector b bueno ahora la pregunta
que quiero hacerles en esta segunda
gráfica es qué pasa cuando tenemos un
vector y lo multiplicamos por un escalar
por lo tanto vamos a multiplicar al
vector b por el escalar 2 y bueno
recuerden la definición de la vez pasada
lo único que había que hacer era
multiplicar por 2 cada una de las
componentes 2 por 1 2
por dos son cuatro entonces ya tengo que
dos veces este vector b es igual al 24 y
como se ve esto aquí representado en
esta misma gráfica vamos a tomar un
punto inicial cualquiera camino 2 hacia
la derecha y 4 hacia arriba y tengo este
vector que estoy dibujando aquí este es
mi vector dos veces ven si te das cuenta
cuando multiplicamos por una escalar
también obtenemos un vector y bueno te
das cuenta que este vector y este vector
están muy relacionados es decir dos
veces b es el doble del vector b si te
das cuenta aquí tenemos a b y aquí
tenemos dos veces el vector b tienen la
misma dirección la única diferencia es
que es el doble de largo fíjate bien si
lo pusiéramos en posiciones estándar dos
veces me quedaría hasta acá es decir dos
veces el vector b una vez tras otra y te
das cuenta cuando nosotros multiplicamos
por un escalar lo único que estamos
haciendo es crecer la longitud del
vector cuántas veces no indique el
escalar o bueno en su dado caso reducir
ahora
qué va a pasar si nosotros tenemos un
escalar negativo como en este caso
tenemos menos 4 que es el escalar por b
pues me quedaría menos 4 x menos 8 menos
4 por una menos 4 menos 4 por 2 menos 8
y bueno ya que tengo menos 4 veces ven
cómo lo puedo representar gráficamente
vamos a ponerlo de una vez en posición
estándar entonces como se ve el vector
menos 4 menos 8 vamos a fijarnos en el
origen es decir en el 0 0 y después
tengo menos 4 por lo tanto me tengo que
ir a la izquierda 4 es hasta acá y
después tengo menos 8 por lo tanto me
tengo que ir hacia abajo hasta el número
8 es decir tengo este vector que está
aquí y si te das cuenta es de su punto
inicial este su punto final me quedaría
más o menos un vector así esta es la
representación gráfica de menos 4 veces
el vector ven ahora lo que quiero que
veas es que cuando tenemos un número una
escalar negativo lo único que hacemos es
primero girar mi vector original 180
grados es decir que vaya hacia el otro
lado esto es lo que va a representar el
signo negativo es decir fijémonos en
nuestro vector original el 1
2 y vamos a tirarlo hacia el otro lado
en esta ocasión va a ir hacia abajo y ya
que lo tenemos hacia abajo lo que vamos
a hacer es aumentarlo cuántas veces nos
diga el número al cual está multiplicado
este vector que en este caso era 4 por
lo tanto vamos a hacerlo crecer en esta
ocasión cuatro veces dicho de otra
manera lo que hacemos es que el vector
se volteen completamente y vaya si la
dirección opuesta y esto nos da pie a
pensar en una idea muy importante ya
tenemos la suma y ya tenemos la
multiplicación por escalar de vectores
ahora cómo podemos definir o cómo
podemos pensar la resta de vectores
supongamos que yo tengo el vector no sé
me voy a tomar el vector x que va a ser
el 24 entonces dejan escribirlo el
vector x es el 24 y me voy a tomar otro
vector va a ser mi vector y en este
vector que también es muy importante
porque lo que voy a hacer ahora es
tomarme la diferencia entre estos dos
vectores y voy a decir que el vector que
es el menos uno menos 2 ya tengo aquí
mis dos vectores y ahora la pregunta es
común
defino o como puedo ver la diferencia de
dos vectores
no voy a tomar x menos y como está
definido y bueno si te das cuenta x
menos y es lo mismo que tomarte al
vector x y sumarle menos una vez y es
decir en lugar de pensar en la resta
ahora voy a hacer una suma y voy a
multiplicar el vector por el escalar
menos 1 eso ya lo sé hacer entonces que
me quedaría el vector x es el 24 más y a
éstos dieron que aumentar menos una vez
el vector james es decir menos 1 x menos
1 me da 1 positivo menos 1 x menos 2 me
va a dar 2 positivo entonces es el
vector 12 y si sumamos esto pues ya es
muy fácil recuerda que la suma está
definida componente a componente no
olvides que este es menos james y bueno
la primera coordenada de este vector y
este vector me dan 3 la segunda
coordenada de este vector más la segunda
coordenada este vector me dan 6 es decir
que yo tengo que encontrar gráficamente
que mi resultado sea el 36 así que vamos
a ponerlos en su posición estándar ya
que tenemos en su posición estándar a x
que es el 24 es este de aquí este es mi
vector x ahora me voy
en el vector en el vector que es un
vector cuyas entradas cuyas componentes
son negativas es el menos uno menos dos
así que vamos a dibujarlo menos uno
también en posiciones estándar aquí es
menos uno y aquí es menos dos es decir
caminamos uno a la izquierda y bajamos
dos y entonces aquí encontramos a mi
vector bien tengo mi vector x tengo mi
vector y en este de aquí y ahora la
pregunta es cómo puedo yo encontrar la
diferencia de x - jeff y bueno para esto
vamos a fijarnos primero en el resultado
tenemos que llegar al 36 así que vamos a
ponerlo también en posiciones estándar
bueno no para que no nos confundamos
vamos a ponerlo aquí y tengo que caminar
tres hacia la derecha y seis hacia
arriba y me queda este vector que tengo
aquí tiene un punto inicial y vamos a
bautizarlo como x menos yen bueno ya
tengo este vector y si te das cuentas
más grande que x y es más grande que ya
como llegamos de aquí acá y la respuesta
no es tan difícil lo único que voy a
hacer es poner allí al revés es decir
cómo estoy multiplicando allí por menos
se voltea y lo puedo poner encima de xy
me saldría el mismo vector bueno este
caso eran vectores con lineales así que
vamos a intentar tomar ahora vectores
que no sean con lineales a ver voy a
tomarme el vector 23 a este vector le
voy a llamar el vector x x es igual al
23 y después me voy a tomar el vector ya
que va a ser el que quiero que quiero
voy a tomarme vector menos 4 menos a 6
no mejor - 2 - 4 - 2 así que lo primero
que vamos a hacer es ponerlos en su
posición estándar este de aquí es mi
vector x2 hacia la derecha 3 hacia
arriba y ahora voy a fijarme en el
vector y mi vector que es menos cuatro
menos 2
aquí está menos 4 aquí está menos 2 este
es mi punto final y a continuación 1 el
origen hasta el punto final y me da el
vector y aquí ya tengo mi vector x en el
vector y bien hasta aquí bien hasta aquí
ok ahora lo que voy a hacer es tomarme
la diferencia otra vez de x menos y
entonces al vector x le voy a quitar el
vector y esto
debemos ser mucho más rápido es 2 menos
4 lo cual me da 24 lo cual es 6 entonces
en la primera componente voy a obtener 6
y déjenme ponerlo aquí ya se lo podemos
hacer mucho más rápido y de hecho entre
más práctica tengas no va a ser hasta
mental
2 - menos 4 es lo mismo que 6 y después
voy a tener tres menos menos 23 menos
menos 2 es lo mismo que tres más 2 lo
cual me da 5 entonces ya tengo mis dos
componentes de este vector y vamos a
dibujarlo primero en su posición no
estándar así que me voy a tomar un punto
cualquiera y camina 6 hacia la derecha
hasta camps y 5 hacia arriba es decir
este es mi resultado este sería x menos
en una posición no estándar x menos 10
muy bien ahora como se va a ver si lo
ponemos en la posición estándar más o
menos parecido a lo que tenía que arriba
bueno fíjate bien voy a pararme en yemen
en la cabeza de y voy a caminar 6 hacia
la derecha voy a dibujar encima de y al
vector x menos 10 entonces 6 a ciudad
derecha 5 hacia arriba y wow
llegó a la cabeza de x es decir cuando
yo hago una resta estoy yendo como que
de cabeza a cabeza solamente hay que
tener cuidado pues hay que tener cuidado
de que flecha que flecha vamos este es x
menos la diferencia entre dos vectores
entre el vector x y el vector y bueno es
que esto es muy parecido a la aritmética
se acuerdan en la aritmética que veíamos
veíamos casos como de este estilo
teníamos por ejemplo 7 dejen cambiar de
color este de aquí esté bien entonces
voy a agarrar 7 menos 5 y esto me daba 2
hasta aquí todo bien pero esto también
se puede escribir de la siguiente manera
5 + 2 es igual a 7 estas dos expresiones
son completamente iguales y es justo lo
que tenemos aquí una forma de decirlo es
que tenemos equis y otra forma de
decirlo es que sea que le aumentamos x
menos le va a dar x fíjense bien la
primera forma es verlo como lo habíamos
visto un y de esta fecha con la última
flecha y no sale x menos pero también
hay otra forma de verlo podemos pensar
que sea y le aumentamos x menos y me da
el vector
y bueno ahora se me ocurre preguntarles
cuánto es
x vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa
entonces menos cuatro menos dos me va a
dar menos seis menos dos menos tres me
va a dar menos cinco es decir es el
mismo vector que x menos y es solamente
que con signo contrario a ver vamos a
ver cómo se ve este es mi punto de
inicio bajo cinco unidades y después voy
hacia la izquierda seis unidades y me da
este vector que yo tengo aquí y si te
das cuenta este vector que es yemen os x
es completamente igual que x menos ye
solamente que estaba volteado es decir
en lugar de apuntar hacia arriba apunta
hacia abajo y si lo vemos aquí mismo lo
que tendríamos que ver es que es un
vector que va desde la cabeza de x hasta
la cabeza de y desde el punto final de x
hasta el punto final de idea esto es de
- x y si te das cuenta lo único que está
pasando es que cambia de dirección por
ejemplo vamos a tomar al vector x que ya
sabemos quién es x es igual al 23
entonces voy a ponerlo en una posición
no estándar y tengo que caminar 2s a la
derecha
hacia arriba y me queda que este es mi
vector x ahora la misma manera me voy a
tomar un punto aquí y voy a dibujar a
menos x quieren menos x pues hay que
caminar 2 hacia la izquierda y 3 hacia
abajo y me va a quedar este vector que
yo tengo aquí este es menos x y si te
das cuenta son paralelos son los mismos
vectores tienen la misma magnitud pero
en lo que se diferencian es que van hace
sentido contrario si x sube menos x baja
es el mismo vector solamente que está
apuntando a direcciones contrarias y
bueno todo esto pasa en el plano
cartesiano o en r2 pero qué pasa si nos
vamos a otras dimensiones
supongamos no sé que voy a manejar a
vectores en r 4 entonces tengo aquí a r
4 y bueno como operó con vectores en r 4
vamos a generalizar esta idea y te vas a
dar cuenta que es exactamente lo mismo
no voy a tomar el vector am este va a
ser mi vector a y va a ser el 0 - 1 2 3
recuerda que tiene cuatro componentes
porque estamos en r 4 y ahora me voy a
tomar el vector b que va a ser el 4
los 20 y 5 ya que tengo a yahvé ambos
son vectores ahora cómo puedo cooperar
con estos dos vectores no sea una suma y
además una multiplicación por escalares
y además una resta no voy a poner esta
operación que yo tengo aquí tengo en la
operación cuatro veces el vector a ya
esto le voy a quitar dos veces el vector
b y bueno ahora la pregunta es cómo pero
con vectores en r4 o en cualquier
dimensión es decir toda la teoría que
hemos creado funciona para vectores que
sean multidimensionales y la respuesta
es que si es lo mismo por lo tanto me
voy a tomar cuatro veces el vector a es
decir 4 x 0 - 1 2 y 3 ya esto le voy a
quitar menos dos veces el vector b que
era el 4 menos 2 0 y 5 y bueno primero
tengo que hacer cuatro veces el primer
vector es decir cuatro por cada una de
las componentes sin embargo no funciona
muy bien la parte derecha de este
pizarrón y por lo tanto lo voy a poner
aquí abajo para que no salga todo
borroso así que 4 por 0 0 4 por menos 1
4 por 2 84 por 3 12 ya esto le vamos a
quitar este vector que es 2 por el
vector b es decir 2 por 482 x menos 2
nada menos 4 no lo sé multiplicando por
decir 9 menos todavía 2 por 0 0 y 2 por
5 10 y bueno fíjense como está fallando
el lado derecho de esta pantalla así que
voy a poner el resultado aquí abajo y
voy a bajar esta pantalla porque no sé
qué es lo que está pasando
creo que el pizarrón está poseído tengo
la diferencia de estos dos vectores va a
ser cero menos 80
88 - 4 - menos cuatro menos 44 es lo
mismo que cero por lo tanto 4 menos 4 es
lo mismo que 08 - 0 es 8 y después 12 -
ay qué número era este de aquí a ver
vamos a verlo era 10.000 ya se ve el 10
ahora no se ve el 10 se ve borroso que
bizarros está esto parece como si
hubiera un espíritu atrapado en este
pizarrón
pero bueno doce menos diez es dos y
bueno este fue el resultado de
multiplicar cuatro veces el primer
vector y restarle dos veces
segundo vector y aunque esto no se puede
graficar porque estamos en r 4 lo que
logramos fue generalizar toda esta
información para vectores en cualquier
dimensión y vamos a ver esto más tarde
cuando apliquemos algunos de estos
vectores a espacios multidimensionales